bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
stade siens sont aujourd'hui consacrées
aux façons d'utiliser un fossile les
plus les possibles sont des restes
d'organismes ou d'activités d'organismes
voilà oui qui ont été préservés dans la
roche
ils sont très utilisés par les
scientifiques pour dettes et les
terrains qui les contiennent dire qu'une
couche qui contient le fossile est
équivalente à telle autre qui contient
le même faux cils pour reconstruire
l'évolution des espèces ou bien pour
trouver du pétrole et du charbon qui
sont eux mêmes fait de facile mais ça ce
sont les utilisations normal que les
paléontologues font des faux cils le
monde lui n'a pas attendu que la
paléontologie soit inventée pour trouver
des fossiles la paléontologie est une
invention assez récente et même encore
aujourd'hui la pratique de son noble art
requiert bien des années d'études et du
savoir faire avant d'être capable de
pouvoir expertise et un fossile comme
étant dignes de figurer dans un musée ou
tout juste bons à décorer l'étagère chez
mémé vous êtes littéralement entouré de
fossiles votre quotidien et baignée par
les fossiles des murs de vos maisons au
parvis des églises dédale des rues
piétonnes aux vitrines des magasins
vous n'imaginez même pas à quel point
les choisissons tout autour de vous ils
sont partout soyez attentifs et vous les
verrez cette omniprésence fait que les
gens même s'ils ne sont pas
paléontologue et même quand ils ne sont
absolument pas intéressé par les
possibles et n'en cherche pas on trouve
quand même ils peuvent parfois ne pas
s'en rendre compte
ou bien il peut en faire des trucs des
trucs qu'ils trouvent amusant des trucs
qui trouve jolie ou détruites qui trouve
utile dans cette vidéo nous n'allons
donc pas faire une liste bête et
méchante des usages incongru des
fossiles ça prendrait beaucoup trop de
temps toutes les roches sédimentaires ou
presque contiennent des fossiles et
toutes ces roches ou presque sont
utilisés d'une façon ou d'une autre en
maçonnerie pour faire des murs ou du
béton l'idée de cette vidéo est de vous
montrer des possibles dans l'utilisation
what the fuck n'a d'égal que leur
importance même du point de vue
scientifique des fossiles que des gens
ont possédé pendant des années sans même
réaliser à quel point il pouvait changer
notre vision du monde un changement
complet de perspectives réduit
y'a un simple bibelot voire même moins
que ça et c'est parti pour les cinq
utilisation et plus what the fuck de
fossiles qui se sont avérées
révolutionné la science
[Musique]
en 1924 le chasseur de fossiles d'un
homme brown est au sommet de sa gloire
20 ans plus tôt il découvrait
tyrannosaurus rex le plus grand
dinosaure carnivore connu à cette époque
est certainement celui qui reste encore
aujourd'hui le plus célèbre barnum et
son bébé
si je puis dire font la couverture des
livres des journaux et remplissent les
salles de conférence et de cinéma barnum
brawn et son t-rex sont des stars et
voilà qu'en 1924 dan brown entreprend un
voyage en grèce pour fouiller les ruines
d'une école de médecine de la grèce
antique
mais il ne s'agit pas de n'importe
quelle école de médecine il s'agit de
celle de cos là où le plus fameux encore
hippocrate à étudier hippocrate tués nir
we7 hippocrate la l'hypocras du serment
d'hippocrate que les médecins restent
encore aujourd'hui watros bien et alors
qu'est ce qu'il a trouvé van den brande
dans l'école de médecine d'hippocrate
accroche toi bien il a découvert aussi
well by foule il trouve un fossile je
vois pas bien en quoi ça change de
d'habitude mais non tu ne comprends pas
il a découvert la dent d'un éléphant
fossiles de l'espèce paléologue ce don
antique eu une espèce qui était déjà
éteintes depuis plusieurs milliers
d'années avant même que la civilisation
antique grecque n'apparaissent ce
fossile était déjà un fossile du temps
des grecs à j'ai compris c'est un faux
site que des grecs ont découvert et
qu'ils ont intentionnellement placé à
l'école de médecine
oui et ceux des centaines d'années avant
l'invention de la paléontologie
alors les grecs étaient déjà des
paléontologues pourquoi qu'il était un
peu ouais mais alors ça veut dire que
cette dent fossiles a tenu dans la main
d'un des plus grands chasseurs de
dinosaures il ya presque cent ans de
cela et qu avant ils avaient
probablement été tenus par l'un des plus
grands pères fondateurs de la médecine
moderne il ya près de dix mille ans et
des millions d'années avant cela elle a
appartenu à l'un des plus grands
mammifères terrestres qui existait sur
terre oui mais si ça se trouve c'est
hippocrate lui même qui a découvert
cette dent
sans aller jusque là il est très
probable que le cndd en est néanmoins
servi à son éducation
ghoul impossible d'une espèce éteinte
qui est passé dans les mains de deux
figures historiques séparée elle même
par deux mille ans c'est l'histoire qui
rejoint la préhistoire vous connaissez
probablement ce fossile car nous en
avons déjà parlé dans une précédente
vidéo
il s'agit d'un cerveau de baleines du
miocène parfaitement préservé ce
possible est une petite révolution à lui
tout seul dans le monde de la
paléontologie
en effet les paléontologues s'était
depuis très longtemps déjà fait une
raison
jamais ils n'étudient ray le cerveau
d'une espèce éteinte car le cerveau est
un organe fait de tissus mous trop
délicat pour résister au processus de
décomposition
avant que n'arrive la possibilité à sion
exception faite de cerveau d'un seul et
unique mammouth congelé il est bon quand
même de préciser
ouais moi aussi les congeler ses proies
exactement un fossile qu'il ya une
espèce éteinte quand même bien non par
conséquent les paléontologues s'était
réduit à étudier la boîte crânienne
faisant des moulages de la qualité du
cerveau en espérant que cette dernière
reflétait plus ou moins l'anatomie du
cerveau qu'elle contenait autrefois mais
il faut bien dire ce qui est 6 et les
circonvolutions du cerveau que vous
voulez voir vous risquez d'être déçu
mais ce fossile là n'est pas un moulage
de boîte crânienne c'est un magnifique
cerveau parfaitement préservée avec
toutes ces circonvolutions
ils montrent qu'un organe aussi délicat
que le cerveau peut se préserver en 3d
et la j'insiste il ne s'agit pas de la
préservation de tissus mous tout écraser
comme on la voit sur les dinosaures de
chine où les reptiles marins allemands
non là il s'agit de 3d une belle
préservation en volume qui a résisté aux
outrages des millions d'années et à une
utilisation répétée en tant que cal pour
une porte
quoi qu'est ce que tu viens de dire
abbas ici c'est bien ce que tu as
entendu un ce magnifique fossiles unique
au monde a servi pendant plusieurs
décennies de cale porte et comment c'est
possible
la personne qui l'a découvert n'étaient
pas une spécialiste
alors pour elle c'était tout au plus un
joli caillou voir un bout de corail mais
elle n'imaginait pas ce que c'était en
réalité
[Musique]
parlons maintenant du célé rocade une
gigantesque un proche parent de l'orang
outan est certainement le plus grand
singe qui ait jamais vécu
oui le gie quant au pit acte démontre la
grande diversité passer des grands
singes cette famille dont nous faisons
partie aujourd'hui et qui comptait pas
moins d'une centaine d'espèces autrefois
mais qui maintenant se meurt car elle
n'est plus réduit qu'à six espèces
nous y compris la toute première dans de
gigantesques des cuisses fut découverte
dans les contreforts chinois de
l'himalaya mais pas par des
paléontologues non par un apothicaire la
petite iq web un apothicaire un
pharmacien quoi pharmaciens
tu veux dire que ça c'est un pharmacien
qui se promenaient là le dimanche
et puis bah il a trouvé ça par hasard
qua non je veux dire que gigan topi tes
cuisses provenait de son coin à fossiles
parce qu'en chine les fossiles sont
réduits en poudre
verser dans le thé est utilisée que me
remettre traditionnel coire des fossiles
comme remède
oui les chinois les appels dans et
hausse de drago pigeonnante hobbit et
que ce n'est pas le seul d'ailleurs
l'homme de pékin ou encore kate chose
aux russes ont été découverts dans des
gisements d'une incroyable richesse qui
sont exploités depuis des générations et
des générations afin de fabriquer des
remèdes traditionnels des boîtes
estampillé dans et aux deux dragons ils
en produisent et centaines de tonnes
chaque année
mais c'est fou ça et vu ce que ça retire
à la science j'espère au moins que ça
marche
benon non pas vraiment en tout cas pas
au delà de l'effet placebo
mais ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que la
mésaventure de gigantesques des cuisses
à démontrer l'extrême richesse du
registre fossile chinois et la grande
connaissance que les populations locales
on ne sait gisement car ça fait
longtemps qu'ils exploitent
ah oui pas étonnant qu'aujourd'hui les
noms de la littérature scientifique de
nouveaux dinosaures à plumes de reptiles
marins et de fossiles cambrien ils ont
en fait une véritable longueur d'avancé
n'oublions pas quand même que
l'utilisation des fossiles comme remède
n'est pas uniquement limitée à la chine
jusqu'à récemment en europe étaient
utilisés pour leurs vertus curatives
lambres mais b limitent les oursins et
les dents de requin ou encore d'ours des
cavernes tu dis était mais moi j'ai
encore vu y'a pas longtemps des
possibles utilisé en vidéo thérapie
oui avoue qu'il use écouter
s'il vous plaît sauvez un fossile
soignez vous plutôt à base de plantes
on entre dans le top 3 attendez vous à
de l'inattendu qui te dire ça autant et
environs mais aujourd'hui c'était un
petit reptile aquatique qui vivait au
permien il y à 280 millions d'années les
fossiles de mai au zoo russes sont
certainement parmi les plus importants
qui était retrouvé dans l'histoire de la
paléontologie
car ils sont à la fois représentées dans
le registre fossile d'afrique et
d'amérique du sud
la présence de mezzo russe sur ces deux
continents aujourd'hui bien distincts
suggère donc qu autrefois il ne former
qu'un le gondwana il fut donc utilisé
comme argument fort soutenant la théorie
de la dérive des continents
le tout premier fossile de mai au zoo
russe fut découvert au 19e siècle en
afrique du sud
il s'agit d'un magnifique petit
squelette tout articulé est parfaitement
préservé une merveille qui est
aujourd'hui jalousement gardé par le
muséum d'histoire naturelle de paris
ovide son importance cette découverte
aurait dû être accueilli comme un
triomphe la personne qui la trouvaient a
dû être couverts de gloire sa renommée
doit aujourd'hui être sans fin non non
non comment ça non
ben non juste non ce fossile a été
découvert par un bushman qui s'en
servaient comme couvercle pour une
casserole une casserole
ah bah oui effectivement c'est pas
glorieux non c'est sûr évidemment
puisque c'était à l'époque de la
colonisation il est inutile de préciser
que le crédit de la découverte ne lui a
pas été attribué à barret 10 dont le nom
du découvreur n'est même pas mentionné
dans la description originale du fossile
et et non il n'ya pas de place dans
l'histoire pour les vaincus
[Musique]
restons en afrique du sud avec la
découverte de l'enfant de tang le
premier australopithecus jamais
découvert et le premier fossile au monde
à avoir démontré que l'origine de
l'homme était en afrique
vous croyez certainement que l'uci avait
été le premier australopithèques
découvert mais lui si c'était dans les
années 70 bien avant cela
en 1924 avait été découvert l'enfant de
tang australopithecus africanus avant
1924 les scientifiques connaissent est
homo erectus de chine
et l'homme de néandertal en europe il
semblait donc impensable que l'origine
de l'homme soit en afrique
c'était pourtant la vie de charles
darwin est aussi celui de raymonde art
le paléoanthropologue sud africain qui
découvrit le spécimen
mais ce n'est pas d'arte qui découvrit
ce fossile mais les mineurs qui
travaillaient à extraire la calcite de
la grotte où il fut trouvé la mine de la
ville de tain produisait plusieurs
tonnes de quel site en faisant sauter à
la dynamite des concrétions stalactites
et stalagmites présente dans cette
ancienne grotte
les fossiles pris dans laquelle si tu
étais le plus souvent détruits avec elle
qui sait combien ont ainsi été perdues à
jamais mais de temps à autre à spécimens
suffisamment complets été ramené au
directeur de la mine qu'il ait conservé
comme de curiosité c'est ainsi que
l'enfant des tang c'est incroyable petit
crâne sur lequel l'empreinte de la boîte
crânienne et préserver fini sur le
bureau du directeur de la mine en tant
que presse papier après ce papier dont
ils n'avaient pas idée de l'inestimable
valeur avant la visite de raymond d'arte
cette visite allait à tout jamais changé
l'histoire des origines de l'humanité en
enracinant pour la première fois
l'origine de l'homme profondément sur le
continent africain
racine où elle se trouve toujours malgré
ce que la presse à sensation mal
renseigné essaie d'en dire
c'est enfin le top 1 le grand final la
dernière frontière
mais quel est donc l'utilisation de faux
cils l'ap le what the fuck qui ait
jamais été fait jusqu'à présent il était
admis que les fossiles dont nous avons
parlé ont tous été découverts dans des
temps relativement récente par homo
sapiens seule espèce humaine qui
existent encore mais maintenant si je
vous disais que homo sapiens n'est pas
la première espèce humaine à avoir
découvert des fossiles qui veut parler
d'une espèce mais les teintes qui à son
époque a découvert des fossiles qui
était déjà des fossiles d'espèces
éteintes depuis longtemps c'est
exactement ça j'ai hâte j'ai hâte
et attention voici pour vos yeux ébahis
un fossile qui a été découvert par nos
cousins les hommes de néandertal au
paléolithique il y a deux cent mille ans
et qui a été modelé en au clip vip à ce
stade il s'agit d'un galet de silex
contenant un fossile de coquillages
datant du crétacé de presque 100
millions d'années il a été collecté par
un homme de néandertal qui vivait en
angleterre il ya deux cent mille ans et
qui a taillé tout autour du fossile à
tibi face d'une façon telle que le
fossile n'a pas été abîmée
cela démontre l'habileté de néandertal
et illustre surtout que cet homme
préhistorique qu'on représente souvent
sous la forme d'une brutes incultes
était en fait un être raffiné
néanderthal avait un vrai sens de
l'esthétique
mieux encore on a retrouvé ce bifaces
vieux de 400 milles en 7 fois et donc
fabriqué par un ancêtres de néanderthal
un prêt néandertaliens il contient un
ours à en silex date est lui aussi du
crétacé et qui fut délibérément ramasser
et tailler de façon à créer un outil à
la fois utile et
éthique des exemples comme ceux là sont
légion et peuvent être tracés jusqu'à
près de 800 mille ans et peut-être même
plus certain possibles sont parfois
retrouvés dans des sites paléolithiques
à des milliers de kilomètres de leurs
gisements d'origine témoignant ainsi
d'une véritable recherche de ces
vestiges des temps qui déjà pour les
hommes préhistoriques étaient anciens il
collectionnait et pratiquer des échanges
peut-être même du commerce de faux cils
cette recharge actifs d'objets de
curiosité et cette volonté de sculpter
l'objet afin d'en préserver la partie
contenant le fossiles attestent d'une
vraie recherche de la beauté
néandertal c'est compliqué drôlement la
vie pour tailler de tels pierre et cela
nous montre qu'il avait le sens de l'art
ainsi c'est possible nous montre que le
sens du beau n'est pas que le propre de
l'homme moderne et surtout que la
paléontologie n'est pas une invention si
récente que ça finalement
évidemment ceci était une liste non
exhaustive alors si vous connaissez des
utilisations folle de fossiles n'hésitez
pas à nous en parler dans les
commentaires et à nous envoyer des
photos si vous en avez à très bientôt
[Musique]